so as in so many mathematical questions
it's free and as find the pretty room
okay there's our premium rule what is it
now all I need to take advantage of in
this case is I don't need calculators I
don't need any you know cos inverse this
whatever I just need to know that the
relationship between sine and cosine is
this relationship it's a complementary
relationship okay so looking at this you
can see it's more or less matches what I
am what we concluded when we're trying
to generalize this patent right trying
to make it true for any angle it's the
sine of some angle there we go
is most some angle is cosine of some
other related a so here's why we write
sine of 47 that's my theta is gonna be
closed off to my good at the compliment
90 take away 47
there's my compliment okay which is I
mean you could reach me a calculator but
it's simple enough right
47 is gonna match up to 43 okay so there
you go
doesn't very difficult was it X is 43
that's not hard okay we're down to
question 3 it starts to get a little
trickier
okay
they present you some information right
by the way that's um and some kalfa
that's a feed off be with the tail on it
which great that's why we say alphabet
anyway
if sine alpha is equal to that and they
tell you this relationship between alpha
and beta in other words they are
complementary you see that they're going
to answer no needs this kind of
situation right they asked for three
kings they want
pause beta cos alpha
beat up right now all I know about these
two a was apart from the fact that they
complementary is I know this right so I
can get this in terms of this if I use
this relationship so in others I'm
trying to sort of assemble a jigsaw here
right so cos beat up I can see that beta
is 90 take away alpha did you see that
when you write it in P I'm just gonna
take away alpha from both sides that
gives me that okay
so everywhere I see beta I could
substitute out for ninety degrees minus
alpha it the same thing so that's cause
all alpha we just took advantage of this
relationship do it it's right here okay
it's equal to
that's the complement of alpha so I can
say that's sine of alpha which of course
you know you just got told for you begin
that's team now if I go to the next one
they want cos alpha okay this is a bit
stickier right you think I've already
used up my relationship that I knew here
before right so now what direction do I
go in think back I'll ask you again when
we first met sine and cosine and tan
where did we meet them in what kind of
shape we met them in right angle angles
right right angle train so this even
though then given you a picture this
implies a picture right it implies a
picture where there's a ratio between
two sides for Norwich two they are and
that's the ratio okay so if a picture is
implied give them a picture
here we go use my right angle triangle
if I've got alpha and beta being
complimentary I'm gonna put alpha yeah
yeah okay because those two angles are
gonna add tonight now sine alpha equals
5 over 13 let's take this and try and
put that data on through our diagram
right
sine is which relationship again
opposite on hypotenuse opposite means so
if that's where I'm looking from it
that's my viewpoint my perspective and
opposite and hypotenuse are these guys
right so that should be the ratio 513
okay five and thirteen now the reason
why that's useful is cuz this is a right
angle triangle we've been doing trig
with right angle triangles but go all
the way back like you're seven an eight
what else do you know about writing in
triangles think old Greek I with an
awkward name yet vision Pythagoras is
there right if I do five and thirteen if
I don't choose sides I can work out the
last side okay now you can go ahead you
can reach for your calculator this
squared plus this squared equals this
squared but sort of want to get to the
point where you thinking I think I
recognize this right like you never I
said three four five is a very common
right angle triangle ratio right by the
way that has a name when you've got
three numbers a triad they're quarter
because for Pythagoras pack the Corinne
triad right pretty much the next most
common one is this guy five twelve
thirteen okay five this the teen what
I'm missing is twelve and you can go
ahead and check it out right the square
is 25 squares 144 squares 169 they add
up okay just the creamier the next one
is eight fifteen seventeen okay so you
can start to recognize these messages we
try to be original but you know these
come up over and over again so you
should recognize it so now I know what
this site is so if I want cos alpha come
back to my other color that's adjacent
over hypotenuse so which pair of size am
I gonna
twelve or thirteen lost on there looking
for so I look into that question yes IBM
now you got two ways to look at this
right you can do this the same way we
did this right because this should be
cause of 90 minus beta 90 minus beta
will be alpha like you can look at the
other room
or you can just take advantage of that
diagram that you beautifully just drew
right sine beta this guy over here
opposite or not is Tom 13 because these
guys alpha beta are complementary you
see that that's why they are equal